the NES classic is out in stores soon
it's sold out on Amazon but we got a
copy here in the office early so we're
going to open it up and see what's
inside now the NES classic the box is
obviously styled after the original
actual nintendo entertainment system so
you have the games on the back all 30
that come packaged with the system but
the console itself is much much smaller
than the original so comes with a
standard paper explanation cards and
opening the box itself a very tiny
console and a little power pack now of
course the original console came with an
RF adapter I don't think you're going to
need that for this one so it comes with
the USB adapter you plug into the wall
one controller that tie it on there
which feels very authentic to the
original NES classic controller the
console itself is the thing you want to
see which is a very tiny Nintendo
console this doesn't opens we can
actually put little cartridges in it we
have a start and power reset button on
the front you have the adapters here
which the Nintendo controller plugged
into which have the same port as the
weed remote controller plugs in there
and on the back you have a DC n for the
power cable and the power cable is
hidden further in the box and a secret
part it comes with an hdmi cable in case
you somehow run out of those normally
the paperwork that comes with these is
pretty boring here's the instruction
manual telling you you know not to take
a bath of it this one comes with a
poster oh my gosh it's like an
old-school Nintendo game that comes with
a cool poster with lots of things that
you're not going to find is a game like
rob the robot and the zapper that's
still pretty sick
and we also got sent an extra second
controller which I assume will be very
similar to the controller that's already
here it is it's the exact same
controller and just to get a look at the
length of the controller to the console
not super long so you're going to sit
pretty close to the TV unless you have a
really long hdmi cable and you want to
play that but this is the NES classic it
is coming out on November 11 if you can
find it in stores get kind of sold out
quickly and it will cost sixty dollars